[Music]
foreign
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said the one who builds a masjid for the
sake of allah
allah will build for him a similar house
in jannah
we want to establish
an amazing masjid for the sake of allah
in the country of norway one of the most
northern countries of the world
if you donate for the sake of allah to
establish this masjid then he subhanahu
ta'ala will give you the reward
insha'allah for every single person who
becomes a muslim in this masjid for
every single person who starts
practicing the deen from the da'wah that
we give in this masjid when they pray
their salawat when they fast in the
month of ramadan when they give in
charity
every single good deed that they do you
will insha allah get the reward for that
if you donate something small maybe a
hundred dollars maybe fifty dollars or
whatever you can for the sake of allah
and
allah said
[Music]
click on the link
and donate now for the sake of allah and
share the video it's absolutely free and
you will get extra reward for everyone
else to participate in this amazing